today
a jury in minnesota
found former minneapolis police officer
derek chovan
guilty on all counts in the murder
of george floyd's last may
it was a murder in the full light of day
and it ripped the blinders off for the
whole world to see
the systemic racism the vice president
just referred to
there were systemic reasons as a stain
on our nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans
profound fear and trauma the pain the
exhaustion
that black and brown americans
experience every single
day the murder of george floyd
launched a summer protest we hadn't seen
since the civil rights year in the 60s
protests that unified people of every
race and generation
in peace and with purpose to say enough
enough enough of this senseless killings
today today's verdict
is a step forward i just spoke with the
governor of minnesota
who thanked me for the close work with
his team
i also spoke with george floyd's family
again
a remarkable family of extraordinary
courage
nothing can ever bring their brother
their father
back but
this can be a giant step forward in the
march toward
justice in america let's also be clear
that such a verdict is also much too
rare
for so many people it seems like it took
a unique and extraordinary convergence
of factors